j'aimerais savoir à propos de bell deux
jours subi nouvelle ce que vous allez
apporter en plus du roman de ce qu'il y
avait dans le roman de joseph kessel
oui j'ai la ligne du roman assez
difficile sur un film moderne avec ça
non une fille passe à cause de la ligne
peu feuilleton des mais j'ai pris les
personnages de s'entendre et séverine et
l'allée changement fondamental avec les
livres avec un clown ont fait le
scénario en interpellant des séquences
de type d'interpellation des équipes
peuvent être imaginées imaginé par ces
verrines ou par nous mêmes il arrive une
certaine confusion dans les films qui
est intéressant c'est que c'est peut
être intéressant
j'ai apporté aux gens après de semences
à des idées interpolé qui sont peut être
imaginé par séverine ont imaginé par où
je ne sais pas on a dit que belle de
jour était votre dernier film j'ai peur
que oui en principe ça va
c'est bon à mes films je n'aime pas
beaucoup plus travaillé je suis un
travailleur extraordinaire pour le shift
ceux capables de passer des mois janvier
en fait vous a fini mais je ne sais pas
j'aimerais savoir ce que vous devez
respectivement à l'espagne au mexique et
à la france est-ce que vous pouvez nous
parler de cela allait passer mais sont
entachés physique est culturellement
c'est mon mes études ma jeunesse mon
enfance mes amis dont je crois que je
suis espagnol
mais d'un autre côté je dois ma
formation aux produits et spirituelle
non à la france beaucoup parce que à
cause d'une roue sur liste je suis allé
à paris
je suis français dans les groupes et je
dois beaucoup
peut-être seulement deux personnes cette
expérience souverainistes au mexique
je vois très peu à la cuisine j'aime
beaucoup le pays ces super eagles
mais ces suies étrange à la culture
indienne en principe à n'arrange pas
tout ce qu'ils ne viennent pas dans nos
civilisations c'est à dire l'art
chrétien qui viennent la grèce rome la
catena vraiment la domotique chasser les
champs avec le coeur et l'autre à
réchapper l'exotique ménage tout à fait
soi même pour que la guinée n'est pas
chrétien mais lorsque le chien andalou
est sorti au cinéma ursulines à paris
vous étiez dans la salle bien sûr mais
vous aviez des cailloux plein les poches
est ce qui vous arrive encore de de vous
rendre à une projection d'un nouveau
film avec des cailloux plein les poches
en passant public
aujourd'hui vous pouvez mais son passé
déjà dense était pour la sauver les
cailloux pas pour défendre mon film mais
pour défendre j'irai les idées du groupe
huntsman s'étaient désintéressés
aujourd'hui ils avaient le même caillou
16 hélène hôtels aux français sa dignité
sa vanité d'artistes français donc c'est
pas la peine ce caillou et morale